[Music]
this morning in our Saturday sessions
Alejandro Escovedo a musician who truly
crosses boundaries from leading a punk
band that opened for the Sex Pistols to
his latest album his 11th recorded with
an Italian band in Rome his remarkable
career has been hard to define I had the
chance to talk with the music pioneer at
the Power Station at Berkeley Studios
here in New York Alejandro Escovedo
'he's latest solo album a suite of songs
about a couple of immigrant kids in
Texas is called the crossing
[Music]
we've had a lot of crossings in your
life effectively I have the son of
Mexican immigrants Escovedo grew up in a
family of musicians including his older
brothers coke and Pete who played with
Santana and Pete's daughter Sheila E who
played with Prince I think out of the 12
children there's eight professional
musicians Wow
that's pretty amazing so music was just
always part of our thing but the music
business often didn't know what to make
of it
radio programmers would say we already
have one Mexican band we don't need
another one
that was los Lobos who they had at the
time and one radio programmers said we
can't even pronounce his name how do you
expect us to play his music so how do
you push back against that you just
fight harder I think you know I just dug
deeper into my music and I knew that I
had something to say he said it with the
San Francisco punk band the nuns who
opened the Sex Pistols final show in
1978 in the 80s he moved to Austin Texas
joined the band rank and file and then
formed the true believers before
launching his solo career in the 90s
when no Depression magazine proclaimed
Escovedo the artists of the decade
[Music]
but late in the 90s he learned he had
hepatitis C and in 2003 collapsed on
stage and had to be rushed to an
emergency room where they found I was
bleeding internally in three different
places what happened to your spirits in
the middle of all this well in the
beginning it was devastating I was in
deep depression you put down your guitar
for how long it was a couple of years
yeah you know why did to all my friends
who we'd all did the same things but yet
I was the one that was chosen to carry
this right and so in a way there was a
point where I kind of blamed the music
for where I was but a group of fellow
artists rallied behind him including
Lucinda Williams and recorded the album
por vida a tribute to the songs of
Alejandro Escovedo
[Music]
yeah that was the medicine that started
to bring me back out of the depths of
that darkness because you realized how
much people appreciated you it suddenly
dawned on me what kind of effect we had
had on people yeah
and that maybe you should be back out
there yes exactly
yeah glad you are well thank you yeah
so my